BORDER IS A POLITICAL STUNT.
>> THANK YOU.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT TO EXPECT
TOMORROW NIGHT WITH THE RESULTS,
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE HOUSE.
JOINING US NOW, HOUSE SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN.
IN JANESVILLE WISCONSIN.
MR. SPEAKER, THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME YOU ARE
NOT ON THE BALLOT SINCE 1998.
YOU ARE FINISHING THIS CAMPAIGN.
TELL NICK WHERE YOU STARTED, IN
SOUTHERN WISCONSIN IN THE
DISTRICT YOU'VE REPRESENTED
SINCE THEN.
YOUR SENSE TONIGHT AND WHERE
IT'S TOMORROW.
>> I FEEL GOOD.
I'VE BEEN CRISSCROSSING NOT JUST
WISCONSIN BUT AMERICA,
CAMPAIGNING WITH OUR MEMBERS IN
THE TOUGHEST RACES.
FRANKLY OUR MEMBERS FEEL REALLY
GOOD BECAUSE THEY HAVE A REALLY
GOOD MESSAGE, BRET.
LOOK AT WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE IN CONGRESS WITH THE
PRESIDENT THE LAST TWO YEARS.
RECORD ECONOMY, MILITARY BEING
REBUILT, PEOPLE FEELING BETTER
ABOUT THINGS, MORE JOBS BEING
OFFERED IN AMERICA THAN
PEOPLE -- BECAUSE OF ALL OF
THIS, OUR CANDIDATES FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE A GREAT MESSAGE.
THE ALTERNATIVE IS THE CHAOS AND
DYSFUNCTION THAT THE DEMOCRATS
ARE BASICALLY PROMISING IF THEY
GET CONTROL OF CONGRESS.
WE REALLY FEEL LIKE WE'VE GOT A
GOOD SHOT KEEPING OUR MAJORITY
BECAUSE OUR MAJORITY IS SO GOOD
AND THE CONTRAST IS SO STRONG.
>> Bret: MR. SPEAKER,
POLITICAL REPORTED THAT YOU
CALLED PRESIDENT TRUMP SUNDAY TO
PLEAD WITH HIM TO FOCUS ON THE
ECONOMY ON THE CLOSING ARGUMENT.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME THAT
THEY DON'T GET THESE THINGS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
HE AND I TALK ALL THE TIME.
WE COMPARE NOTES ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
WE'VE BEEN SPEAKING REPEATEDLY
THROUGHOUT THIS CAMPAIGN CYCLE
IT JUST THE LAST FEW WEEKS SO WE
ARE ALWAYS COMPARING NOTES ABOUT
THE CAMPAIGN ABOUT MESSAGING.
HE FRANKLY CALLED ME TO SEE HOW
CERTAIN MEMBERS ARE DOING.
HE CARES ABOUT A LOT OF OUR
MEMBERS.
WE CAN DO BOTH.
PEOPLE DO CARE ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE WANT TO SECURE THE BORDER.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO ABOLISH
I.C.E.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
WE DO THINK WE SHOULD BE TALKING
ABOUT OUR STRONG ECONOMY BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN SPECTACULAR AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT
ROLLING BACK AND RAISING TAXES,
MORE SPENDING, THEY ARE
PROPOSING TO UNDO ALL THE GOOD
PROGRESS WE'VE BEEN HAVING.
I WOULD SIMPLY ASK PEOPLE, DO
YOU FEEL BETTER TODAY THAN YOU
DID TWO YEARS AGO.
GET OUT AND VOTE TOMORROW.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT AND I
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
WE CAN TALK MORE THAN ONE ISSUE.
WE HAVE A GOOD STORY TO TELL
ABOUT THE ECONOMY, WAGES, JOBS,
OPPORTUNITIES, ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT THEM, WE THINK IT'S A
GOOD STORY TO TELL.
>> Bret: ABOUT TAXES.
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY PASSED A MAJOR
TAX REFORM BILL, IT PASSED THE
HOUSE, PASSED THE SENATE, HERE
IS THE PRESIDENT ON TAX CUTS ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE PUTTING IN
A 10% TAX CUT FOR MIDDLE-INCOME
FAMILIES.
IT'S GOING TO BE PUT IN.
PASSING A MASSIVE TAX CUT.
MASSIVE!
WE WILL SOON FOLLOW IT UP WITH
ANOTHER 10% TAX CUT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
WE'VE GOT TO WIN THE HOUSE.
>> Bret: IN ADDITION TO THE
FIRST ROUND, TO DO A SECOND
ROUND 10% TAX CUT FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS, THE SPECIFICS OF THAT
NEVER CAME OUT BEFORE TOMORROW.
WAS THERE A SPECIFIC PLAN?
IS THERE A SPECIFIC PLAN?
>> I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT A
NUMBER OF TIMES ABOUT THIS AS
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE WAYS AND
MEANS COMMITTEE, AND WE PASSED
IN THE HOUSE ALREADY A BILL
MAKING THE FAMILY TAX RELIEF
MEASURES AND PERMANENT.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO DO
ON TAX REFORM 2.0, THE NEXT
SESSION OF CONGRESS, GO ON IT
AGAIN AND GET A MIDDLE CLASS TAX
RELIEF.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
WE THINK SOMETHING THAT CONGRESS
SHOULD WORK ON IN THE NEXT
SESSION.
THE ECONOMY IS GOING IT'S REALLY
WELL LARGELY BECAUSE OF TAX CUTS
AND TAX REFORM, AND THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO KEEP THIS
ECONOMY GOING WITH ANOTHER KICK
AT IT.
>> Bret: SO FAR IT'S NOT A
SPECIFIC PLAN THAT'S GOING TO BE
ROLLED OUT.
>> THE WAY TAX LAWS WERE, THE
WAYS AND MEANS COMMITTEE CAN
COME UP WITH MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
TO GET A 10% TAX CUT FOR MIDDLE
INCOME TAXPAYERS AND THEIR WAYS
TO DOING IT ON A REVENUE PER
REVENUE BASIS.
SOMETHING THEY ARE GOING TO WORK
THROUGH THE PROCESS TO GETTING
THE NEXT OF CONGRESS.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE IN
THE NEWS RECENTLY IS THIS
BACK-AND-FORTH ON CITIZENSHIP,
THE PRESIDENT SAYING THAT HE CAN
DO IT WITH AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
YOU SAID THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
YOU ARE ASKED ABOUT THAT ON THE
TRAIL.
THE PRESIDENT WEEDED OUT AFTER
SEEING THAT, TOLD RYAN SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON HOLDING THE MAJORITY
THAT GIVING HIS OPINIONS ON
BIRTHRIGHT CITIZENSHIP,
SOMETHING HE KNOWS NOTHING
ABOUT.
A NEW REPUBLICAN MAJORITY WILL
WORK ON THIS, CLOSING
IMMIGRATION LOOPHOLES AND
SECURING OUR BORDER.
WHAT ABOUT THAT, MR. SPEAKER?
>> IT'S ALL GOOD.
HE AND I HAVE A VERY LONG, VERY
GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
WE TALKED THAT THEY LATER ON.
I WAS COMMENTING ON THE MEANS,
NOT THE MERITS.
WE SHOULD REVIEW THIS,
ESPECIALLY FOR ILLEGALS AND
PEOPLE GETTING A TOURIST VISA
JUST TO GET A KID.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD LOOK
AT BECAUSE THIS IS THE
21ST CENTURY, IT'S NOT THE 18TH
CENTURY WHEN THAT WAS WRITTEN.
WHAT I WAS COMMENTING ON ARE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL MEANS OF
ACHIEVING SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
IT'S EITHER A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT OR STATUTORY CHANGE
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED.
EXECUTIVE ORDER CAN ENFORCE A
COURT CHALLENGE.
I DON'T THINK THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER CAN MAKE THE CHANGE.
THAT EITHER HAS TO BECAUSE
ADDITIONAL OR AT THE VERY LEAST
STATUTORY.
I WAS TALKING ABOUT A LEGAL
PROCESS ABOUT ACHIEVING
SOMETHING FOR IT BUT SHOULD WE
LOOK AT WHETHER OR NOT IN THE
21ST CENTURY SOMEONE COMING OVER
WITH A TOURIST VISA FOR THE SAKE
OF HAVING A BABY HERE THAT CAN
GET CITIZENSHIP?
THAT SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE REVIEWED.
>> Bret: YOU SPENT THE LAST
THREE WEEKS IN 50 CITIES IN 12
STATES, 25 DIFFERENT HOUSE
MEMBERS, YOU RAISE 200 MILLION
PLUS HARD DOLLARS THE PAST THREE
YEARS ON THIS EFFORT.
IF THE HOUSE LIPS TOMORROW, WHY
WOULD THAT HAVE HAPPENED?
>> HISTORY IS NOT OUR FRIEND.
WHAT I SAY IS THE HISTORIC
AVERAGE FOR A MIDTERM ELECTION,
THE PRESIDENT'S PARTY AND THE
PRESIDENTS MIDTERM, WE HAVE A 20
SEAT MAJORITY.
A COUPLE OF OUR SEATS ARE
ALREADY GONE BUT RECENT
REDISTRICTING DONE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE ALREADY ARE STANDING AGAINST
THE HISTORICAL TREND THAT CUTS
AGAINST US.
BUT THE REASON I FEEL LIKE THIS
IS GOING TO BE REALLY, REALLY
CLOSE AND I FELT CAUTIOUSLY
OPTIMISTIC IS BECAUSE OF OUR
RECORD.
WE HAVE DONE SO MUCH.
OVER A THOUSAND BELLS IN THE
HOUSE THE PAST TWO YEARS,
TACKLING OPIOID, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, OVERHAULING THE VA.
DEREGULATING THE ECONOMY,
CREATING JOBS AND WAGES,
OVERHAULING THE TAX SYSTEM AMONG
EVERY OTHER THINGS.
THE ENORMOUS RECORD OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
MOST OBJECTIVE AMERICANS WOULD
SEE THAT THE COUNTRY IS BETTER
OFF THAN IT WAS TWO YEARS AGO
AND THEY DO NOT WANT TO SEE THE
DEMOCRATS, NANCY PELOSI, TAKE
POWER TO BRING CHAOS AND
GRIDLOCK TO WASHINGTON.
THEY WILL TRY TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT TO ABOLISH I.C.E.,
THAT'S THE AGENCY THAT STOPS
DRUGS COME DOWN THEN COMING INTO
OUR COUNTRY.
PLUS $32 TRILLION TAX INCREASE
TO PAY FOR IT.
THAT'S WHY I THINK WE'VE GOT A
REALLY GOOD CHANCE BECAUSE
HISTORY, ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT OUR
FRIEND, WE GOT A GOOD RECORD
THAT CAN HELP COMBAT THAT.
>> Bret: LESSON QUICK,
MR. SPEAKER.
I'VE COVERED YOU FOR A LONG
TIME.
I'VE COVERED YOU AS
VICE PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEE, YOUR
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH, WE CAN'T
SPEND MONEY THAT WE DON'T HAVE.
THE DEBT CRISIS IS GOING TO HIT
US EVENTUALLY.
THIS YEAR, THE FEDERAL DEFICITS,
$779 BILLION, CBL IS PROJECTING
$973 BILLION FOR 2019,
$100 TRILLION FOR 2020.
IS THAT GOING TO BE ADDRESSED?
>> AND HAS TO BE ADDRESSED.
BRET, THE NUMBERS DON'T SURPRISE
ANYBODY.
THAT'S BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS,
THE BABY BOOMERS ARE RETIRING,
WE ARE NOT READY FOR THEM'S.
IN ADDITION TO GUARANTEEING
PRODUCTIONS FOR PEOPLE WITH
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS, WE HAVE
GIVEN PEOPLE MORE CHOICES, BUT
IT WILL BE A GREAT EFFORT IN
DEBT REDUCTION.
THE HOUSE PASSED THAT BILL.
THE BIGGEST WE'VE CONSIDERED IN
A GENERATION.
THIS ENTITLEMENT REFORM BILL
WE'VE CONSIDERED IN A GENERATIO
GENERATION, IT FAILED TO PASS
THE SENATE BY ONE VOTE.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO GET BACK AT
THAT BECAUSE WE DO NEED
HEALTH CARE REFORM, WE NEED TO
LOWER PREMIUMS, MAINTAIN THOSE
PROTECTIONS FOR PRE-EXISTING
CONDITIONS, BUT YOU ALSO HAD TO
DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES.
YOU ON THE FLIP SIDE, BRET,
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A GROWING
ECONOMY.
THAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE WE'VE
DONE WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO GET
THIS ECONOMY GROWING.
ON THE ENTITLEMENT SIDE?
YES, THAT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO GET DONE.
>> Bret: YOU SAID YOU ARE NOT
ON THE BALLOT?
>> IT'S BITTERSWEET.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE GUY WHO'S
RUNNING, BRIAN STYLE, I THINK IS
GOING TO DO A SPECTACULAR JOB.
I'VE BEEN ON THE BUS WITH MY
GOVERNOR SCOTT WALKER.
HE'S GOT A TOUGH RACE HERE.
I LOVE THE PEOPLE I CARE ABOUT I
WANT TO SEE WIN.
THEY ARE A LOT OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN CONGRESS IN TOUGH RACES THAT
HAVE DESERVED AND EARNED A
REELECTION.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH MY FOCUS.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR 20
YEARS.
THIS IS THE TENTH ELECTION
CYCLE.
FIRST TIME SINCE 1998 I'VE NEVER
BEEN ON A BALLOT.